ANNOUNCER:
Ladies and gentlemen, the 45th
and final president
of the United States.
-(cheers and applause)
-(camera shutters clicking)
Yes, it's very sad.
It's very sad.
Very sad.
Well, you knew
what you signed up for,
but thank you for your service.
-Okay. Bye, Melania.
-(laughter)
Mr. President,
how do you respond
to the judges rejecting
yet another travel ban?
I reject their rejection.
It's total fake news.
But, sir, people are calling it
your biggest public failure.
You're the biggest
public failure!
I decide
how big my failures are.
And they're the biggest.
Wait. That's not what I meant.
-Sir, what are you even
accomplishing? -Come on.
-You can't stay mad about...
-(overlapping chatter) -No.
-(overlapping chatter)
-No. Time... freeze!
(horn plays note)
Sometimes I get so frustrated
that I don't know what to do,
so I just freeze time.
I mean, these reporters
are so mean to me.
Why can't they be like
my Fox & Friends?
Like Steve Doocy and Brian Doocy
and Lady Doody,
and the other idiots
who say what I tell them?
Easy, Donald. You're the king.
-Time, unfreeze.
-(horn plays note)
-Mr. President?
-...inappropriate, sir.
-...the question, sir.
-Sir, how do you respond
to Senator McCain's implication
that you're in bed
with half-baked,
spurious nationalism?
I don't respond!
McCain is not my friend!
And you know
who else isn't my friend?
NFL Players, military widows,
Hawaiian judges, Hawaiian pizza,
everyone in The White House,
that "Me Too" hashtag,
and you people!
Uh, yeah,
we're not your friends.
Yeah, I said it first.
You're not my friends!
-(indistinct, overlapping
chatter) -Time... freeze!
(horn plays note)
But I want them to be.
And that's why
tonight's theme is "friends."
They're supposed to make me feel
big and strong and big,
while I make them feel small
and dumb and small!
That's what friends are.
They're there to serve me.
This is my castle,
and I'm the queen.
Oh, I mean the king.
-Time, unfreeze.
-(horn plays note)
-(indistinct chatter)
-Seriously, sir.
You never talk
about the good things I do good.
I made the stock market
a very big number.
I made jobs that people have.
Big jobs. Steve Jobs.
But he's dead,
but that's not my fault.
That happened during Obama,
and he didn't even call!
(laughter)
What are you talking about?
What am I talking about?
I don't like the way
I feel right now.
They made me feel bad
about myself,
so I'm gonna make them pay.
I'll make them pay big time,
believe me.
Um, we can hear you.
Goddamn it, I forgot
to do the time thing!
Whatever.
I'm the king.
-You're the president!
Can you believe it?
Let's roll!